oh [ __ ]
you bad [ __ ] it's wednesday
april 23rd
you're alive
your dick is hard
and somebody's getting ready to suck
some [ __ ] yum yums it's the church of
what's happening now [ __ ] lee
kick this [ __ ] let me see you
wiggle old school lead take it to the
hooply oh [ __ ] prank that [ __ ]
lee
that [ __ ] league
bust their [ __ ] ear balls
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] kick a leaf
give me give me some lovin oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
love is the word of the day suck my dick
is the second word of the day oh
oh
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this is you [ __ ]
[ __ ] the malaysian plane
[ __ ] the pope [ __ ] everybody
oh [ __ ]
what's the story though they're never
gonna find that plane
they said particles [ __ ] came up it's
over those sharks [ __ ]
those sharks are [ __ ] those [ __ ]
people by now it's over it's over lisa
yet wednesday april 23rd [ __ ] 4 20. if
you ain't popping every day you ain't a
[ __ ] soldier at that time it's 2 20.
oh my god
the [ __ ] out of here you [ __ ] almost
what's happening baby man i don't want
to congratulate you oh thank you i'm
taking a walk yesterday i did i took a
little commitments become big
commitments my brother yeah all that
[ __ ] you know what are you gonna do
put a [ __ ] suit on and go jump with a
trainer and after three days you're
gonna be so sore it all starts with
walking if you can't walk you can't do
nothing yeah and i think i think
everything happens for a reason because
i had a [ __ ] up thing happen and now
it looks like i might be moving next to
the hollywood park north park we're
getting thrown out every [ __ ] day
every day we're getting through other
apartments that's what i'm talking about
we live you're slinging dick that didn't
throw you out cause you bumped some
guy's car they threw you out cause they
see you with a smile in your face they
didn't throw me out i'm just not [ __ ]
the pay in the rent there how much is
the rent 1200 so i'm [ __ ] leaving oh
they raised it no no no no this is the
place i've been at i've been at that's
where where it was and i'm just i told
the landlord i'm like
i'm not [ __ ] living here so i'm i
found a place today i'm gonna go look at
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so the guy's
saying that you're hitting this car this
guy i've been there a month and a half
almost two months
like two weeks in he was in my parking
spot writing me a note with my landlord
i think you're hitting my car i'm like i
haven't touched your car my car has no
dings on it
like i just haven't been but i'll be
careful and then a week ago oh and this
i do have one thing to tell people
because it's [ __ ] smart
a week ago i got a call from my landlord
saying he thinks you're still doing it
we're going to move your parking spot
so what you what you [ __ ] do i email
my landlord because now i have a record
of it
it was april 14th when he emailed me and
i said i'm not doing it but i'll move
over so we literally move my parking
spot six feet over
i get a call yesterday
from my insurance company do you have
anything a statement for what happened
on the 15th i'm like what happened on
the 15th nothing happened like you hit a
parked car in a studio city parking lot
i'm like no
they send someone out nothing nothing
happened
so i looked at my email i moved my car
on the 14th he said i hit him on the
15th yeah so you got this done
well the one thing i have to say
get everything in writing
you're [ __ ] favorite because now this
guy's a regular low on audit oh my i
have to call my mom and tell us she was
right because she told me that years ago
so [ __ ] people but now i'm moving to a
bigger nicer place that's right because
you're slinging dick like a pimp on a
tuesday you're following me goddamn
that's why i love you lisa yeah because
you're a [ __ ] soldier of death you
don't even know it
you're just a little jew of death right
now but in [ __ ] who he is you're
gonna be throwing satellites out of your
dick you understand me you're gonna be
pulling the skin back
lasers jewish lasers by the way
passover's over break out the [ __ ]
alka-seltzer
jesus christ it's a week of jews eating
bad food
every jew in america is like jesus
[ __ ] christ
i gotta go gluten-free now [ __ ] those
matzo ball cookies oh my god that's so
gross what else is going on you got
nothing for me on a [ __ ] wednesday
no i mean let's see i know i'm [ __ ]
happy otherwise
[ __ ] i just didn't sleep last night i
was riled up yesterday i was i was like
a jew i was like a jew on fire i almost
wanted to knock down the guys you on
fire you on fire i didn't i don't
luckily i didn't know what apartment
when he was i almost went and knocked on
this door i was i was riled up yesterday
well that's good you calm down how are
you doing you know me dawg i got up
yesterday i went to that it's funny
because
last week at the ufc in orlando which by
the way i got to thank the people of
orlando correctly i had a great [ __ ]
time last week i really did orlando's
and the people that showed up to the
show were world class some guy gave me a
bad [ __ ] wallet some guy gave me
a tray for my weed some guy gave me a
vaporizer i want to give you guys all
love thank you for the presents you know
i love you guys i didn't give you monday
was a [ __ ] up day here
so a lot of things were overlooked that
was supposed to give some kid a shout
out the belly hills film festival just
you know life happens people so i'm
sorry but i love yous all and we [ __ ]
try everything is great i went yesterday
to this i'm at the ufc satellite
and we're getting into a conversation
about karate movies and somebody says
that steven seagal
uh hit somebody in the head with a pool
cue and a sock and out for justice and i
made a statement i go yes he did but it
was first done by chuck norris
in code of silence oh [ __ ] 1983 dennis
farina tremendous [ __ ] movie to
colombians in chicago [ __ ] great uh
chuck norris you know
we don't give enough credit to chuck
norris bruce lee did a lot chuck norris
did a lot for the sport and especially
like tank sudo
it's a division of taekwondo it's a you
know something else something different
these guys kick above the [ __ ] head
whatever
but uh
chuck norris is a bad [ __ ] to
return to dragon with bruce lee when
they fought the coliseum
and uh the octagon is good good guys
where black is good there's a couple
movies chuck norris but i think one of
chuck's best [ __ ] movies was code of
silence 1983.
so i make this statement the guy looks
at me weird the other guy says that's
right you're right the guy goes i don't
think so i'm not going to argue the ufc
i just moved on with my life
i have an audition yesterday for the
untitled warren baby project it's got a
[ __ ] all-star cast like matthew
broderick and [ __ ] martin sheen and
candice bergman and just actors you know
joey diaz and joey diaz and
i go in yesterday the appointments at 11
30. i get there at 10 15. you know me i
don't [ __ ] around
because i don't want to [ __ ] around in
traffic in hollywood there was no
traffic going into hollywood
so i'm the second one there there's some
guy i've recognized from a few movies i
can't remember who it is i'm sitting
there and also the door opens and i look
up and it's the [ __ ] gangster from
code of silence
and he's 70 years old he's got to be 65
66.
and he's in a couple other movies the
guy's a bad [ __ ] i do not know
what his name is if anybody uh is on
imdb look it up and twitter the gangster
from code of silence
i think his uh he was a younger guy but
the old guy is old man scalise and then
he's the younger guy and there's a big
bruno guy
so i'm sitting there
and i look up and it's this [ __ ] guy
from code of sounds
and he's sitting we're sitting there for
five minutes and it's a coat of silence
nobody's saying nothing to each other so
i raised my hand lee i go hey
last saturday i'm at the ufc and some
[ __ ] was talking about steven
seagal
out for justice and i said the scene was
from
a code of silence which you were in he
goes that's right
and after that uh we started talking you
know i didn't even tell him the whole
story
i
yet told him that and then i went inside
they called me and i had to go inside
but when i came out i came right back to
the same point where they called me in
like i was having a conversation because
joey you're ready to go i'll be right
back
i went in i came out and i talked to him
a little more about movies and they told
me a stephen cigal story he was on a
plane with stephen seagal about five
years ago and they were both in first
class and steven cigar got up and he's a
tall guy and his head hit the top of the
of the thing and as he was walking on
the plane he left the streak
he left the streak of ink from dyeing
his hair
so there you go that's your steven
seagal story of the [ __ ] day okay
that's how we rock it here on the church
of what's happening now very interesting
yesterday uh i wanted to ask you
something the other night we had a
discussion and you were talking about
msnbc
oh the joseph yeah can i ask you a
question yeah
why didn't i turn out like one of those
guys why didn't i get tattoos why didn't
i
commit myself to prison what was i
always sit there and watch that show
because that was me
that was me when i was 28. it was lee i
was a knucklehead i wasn't a knucklehead
like that i was a little bit more
intelligent i had a little bit more i
had a lot more common sense than those
guys yeah but i was in that same
predicament and whenever i watch that
show and i look at that show i get
really sad oh really because i want to
grab those guys and go are you [ __ ]
serious
you're going to live a life you're going
to waste a life behind bars with this
mentality
and i know that you like this show and
it makes me feel badly like i get scared
that that was me at one time see the
thing i was gonna say like i i just know
you now so i was gonna say like well you
have heart and then you wouldn't end up
like that but if you if that was you
then
you know what i'm not talking about me
i'm talking about that was like last
week they had a guy in there two weeks
ago you're on the road you're doing
comedy you get back to your room at 11
30. not another time there's nothing not
i'll make a cup of coffee and i'll put
that on okay and i'll watch tv listen
but i'm really writing i'm really on the
computer on facebook or twitter or i'm
writing on lit lift
and i listen to a guy go you know that
this is the only life i know you know
being inside and right away i thought of
gary danny bunculo's
brother and i called danny yesterday
danny called me in the morning and
called him back
and i said to him how's gary doing
because gary's gonna be in there for
life you know gary called into the
podcast a few times and it's amazing
that
he always wanted to go back in even when
he was out and that's what the guy said
he goes i don't feel comfortable outside
in the real world
and that's [ __ ] shocking to me that
yeah you wouldn't feel comfortable
you know the extension of prison going
away is like a big summer camp
if you break it down that way if you
break it down in your head that you're
just going away for summer camp as an
adult
it makes the time go by a lot easier you
know i i went in there looking at four
to six years i didn't go in there
looking at 20 [ __ ] years and i know i
wouldn't make parole i always knew that
i wasn't even gonna go in front of the
parole board when you do a violent crime
you do 80 of your time usually 90 of
your time so they give you 12 years
you're going to do 10 of those [ __ ]
years because you're gonna go from in
front of the parole board and they're
going to deny you they're going to say
that
you're not fully rehabilitated you know
i've been trying to write this chapter
the hardest chapter in this book has
been a book about this guy named mr blue
when i got locked up
mr blue was my counselor okay and he was
an old redneck and the first two months
he didn't like me and i didn't
particularly like camp but like anything
else in life
he saw something and he started talking
to me and giggle he would break his
smile from time to time
and i would always ask him about a file
there's a special date
we discussed they didn't take file like
yeah he said
a test you know and that guy always told
me i was dangerous
all it says is you're a danger and i
used to feel really bad about myself
because at that time i was on an
all-time low you know in my mind you
know i had nothing going on i had no
prospects
i had no future when you have no future
that's a scary proposition you might not
have a job
and you might not be doing what you want
to do but you have a degree you have a
pathway and at least if you walk into
burger king they'll say this guy did
something he went to college for four
years even though it still shocks me
that nobody's ever talked to you about
college
if i bait a cap or whatever
and to have that feeling to feel lost
like that
anything could happen to you when you
don't have any future and you yourself
know i'm telling you i had no [ __ ]
future at that moment in that jail i was
coming out to zero i had money in the
bank i had a girlfriend you know i was
gonna come out to have an apartment i
wasn't going to be like
but i mean emotionally and
as a human being i started from zero i
didn't have a college degree you know i
didn't get my high school [ __ ]
diploma
to right before i got
admitted into the university of colorado
you know it's not i quit school and went
back but i never had enough credits to
graduate and then who you know i was
concerned with living never mind a
[ __ ] diploma yeah so i had all the
makings of a loser at times i still feel
that way only
i pay my rent now you know i have money
to go to groceries
i uh i don't fear
you know you don't know what it is to be
a criminal to go to bed every night not
knowing what tomorrow's gonna bring not
knowing if you're gonna answer
the door to [ __ ] cops knocking or
whatever so when i watch that msnbc show
you know it's just i look at that and i
get scared for a second i get really sad
i say to myself that's me there's no two
ways about it i was in that position
well do you think maybe it had to do
with because you've talked about how you
you went like for a night every once in
a while but like you were never really
in jail before then
do you think maybe i wasn't in prison
before that i had been i had been in
county jails before like days yeah like
a night or three day not even three days
like i always got bailed out i spent the
night got out in the morning so you
never got comfortable like it seems like
a lot of those people
how the [ __ ] they're comfortable i don't
know what the comfort level is well
they're the mattresses suck yeah the
showers suck you know they give you a
little towel you gotta shower with men
around you who stink and [ __ ] all
[ __ ] day you know what men smell like
all [ __ ] day like a zoo you ever go
to a [ __ ] zoo by the apes that's what
it smells like in that [ __ ] thing
right well i mean
i've heard i've seen people on that show
who were alive 30 years and have spent
23 years in some sort of journey
can you believe that and that that and
that's comforted not not
not being able to go to your car not
being able to walk to 7-eleven not they
don't know anything about those little
things
it scared the [ __ ] out of me it scares
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me but
i don't know when i wanted to scare the
[ __ ] out of you then
no at that time i
you know man
after i lost my mother
i lost the fear factor
the the fear of anything because i
wanted to die
when you don't have a mother at that age
and had the things going on around me
you know people buying cars here i was
17 and i had no [ __ ] car i had you
know there were just little things i
always i always felt insecure how it was
now you put the drugs and no mother what
do you think i'm at now loss of religion
because you lose your faith you lose
your inner believings now what what does
that leave you you're just a [ __ ]
you're just a recipe for debt yeah you
know so when i watch that show lee
my question is i don't understand why i
didn't end up like that yeah and i know
that i have the prison mentality
sometimes in my daily life
you know i know i have that criminal
mentality in my daily life but it's
helped me the the the the fire in the
mornings that i have has helped me you
know to do other things
i just can't understand like it scares
the [ __ ] out of me it makes me very
uncomfortable
and uh
that's what i was just maybe it has
something like i and i i don't i'm not a
huge believer in this but i know you are
and i know you you lost your mother and
and you wanted to die and you were so
upset but for the 15 years that you had
her she [ __ ] she loved you and you
and you knew that so i don't know if she
was looking over you or maybe just in
the back like the deepest part of you
you're like you don't want to disappoint
her so maybe like that pushed you i
don't know what no i don't even want to
disappoint anybody especially like i
told you the other day if you take me
give me 50 bucks and let me sleep in
your house
for years i would always call you when
something good happened dog i booked a
commercial
dog i did this because in a way i wasn't
just happy for me i was happy for you
because you believed you wouldn't have
given me those twenty dollars if you
didn't believe right some people give
you twenty dollars to get rid of you
i knew who was giving me twenty dollars
for me to sleep and to live another day
and to have my dream another day which
is the most important thing
is that no matter what happens to you
when you wake up that next day your
dream still has to be [ __ ] strong
whatever your dream or your desire is
for that day still has to be strong
whether you want to
uh go to a vocational school and be a
motorcycle mechanic or you want to be a
transvestite and cut your dick off and
you know whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do you know i laugh at the two guys
across the street from me they're
transvestites in in uh
in progress
like you know they get the shots and the
one guy's hair is growing then you'll
see him and he puts earrings on now he's
got a brawn the guy's been wearing a bra
lately
you know he's turning into a woman right
in front of me it didn't happen in one
[ __ ] day
you know since i've been there the last
five years he's been becoming a [ __ ]
[ __ ] every [ __ ] day you know whatever
the [ __ ] he's doing i like him i talk to
both of them the one is [ __ ] hideous
i don't know how she's going to be a
woman she's really a man she just throws
a wig on like because
yeah big mike
big mike just throws a wig on and says
[ __ ] it that's not having fear you know
that's uh
it's just amazing when you watch those
msnbc shows yeah i walked in those shoes
and i sit there and i still believe that
that was me i still believe in a lot of
ways that was me i don't look down on it
at all i don't uh anybody who talks to
me and emails me and knows that i don't
look down on any of that [ __ ] at all you
know have you ever thought about doing
one of those scared straight things with
kids
to try to get because that doesn't work
it doesn't i i don't listen
nothing
really clicked with me until i did
the work
me bringing you into a prison and
yelling at you
isn't going to show you work isn't going
to show you the inside of it if some big
black guy got him beat you on his head
with his dick
that'll scare the [ __ ] out of you when
you're 15.
but me you yelling in my face yeah it's
just gonna make me walk out of there and
be more
you know to prove you wrong when you're
15. when you're when you're 15 you think
you know everything and your goal is to
prove your parents or whatever society
wrong you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know i
put this tattoo on my face because
people know that when i'm i'm business
you're 15 you [ __ ] idiot that's why
you put a tattoo on your face you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's why they tell you
to bring your mom
that's why they tell you to bring your
mom when you get a tattoo she talks you
out of a [ __ ] tattoo on your face you
[ __ ] idiot but uh
no that that's the real deal glee and it
scares it's it
just wakes me up every [ __ ] day yeah
people the other day some kid asked me
what motivates you the thought of that
so why do you watch the shows at night
yeah as a reminder as a reminder of how
fast things change and how fast things
can't change i could be driving down the
street one day
somebody like cuts me off i flow into
his energy i give him the finger
he throws something at me i throw a
hammer at him he dies
i do 50 years over something [ __ ]
stupid that's how fast your life could
change
that's how fast jesus
by a movement of your [ __ ] temper by
a movement of you having thought it out
that's how fast life could change and as
long as you know that as long as you
know that you could wake up one morning
i could look at me and go i'll see you
at 12 at 11 30 i go to [ __ ] 7-eleven
and try to run some [ __ ] over
with a car and get the rest of the
quarter to 12. that's how fast things
could [ __ ] happen those are the
mistakes i overcome sometimes
i do them because i'm [ __ ] human you
know you have everyone makes mistakes
yeah you get [ __ ] pissed off every
day and things [ __ ] happen you know
let me tell you something
there are people
that i hang out with in la
that when i see them when i leave them
after a few hours i feel like [ __ ]
yeah
like my energy they suck my [ __ ]
energy out they get into my head and
that's dead negativity they they think
that johnny positive they think they're
the best people in the [ __ ] world
but something about their character
that's why when they're around me i know
they're lying i know their whole
existence is a lie as soon as they stand
next to me but i've been around those
people all my life you know you get to
you get to get the people's energy you
get to get you're bumped into something
everybody's seeing you get happy like
steve simon oh [ __ ] yeah whenever you
see steve simone with his new haircut
it's like the sun came out yeah isn't
that [ __ ] up i've always been jealous
of people like that there's always
there's always some person in a group
that i'm in that has no beef with
anybody and everybody no one has any no
one has ever had anything bad to say
about somebody
and like i've always been jealous i've
always wanted that nobody talks bad
about you so there's some people who
don't like me i'm sure i've been an
[ __ ] to somebody or
or or or cut somebody off or did
something i mean there's a there's
always somebody somebody with your car
none you tap your [ __ ] car i'll
[ __ ] flip this table over i
uh but no i just
i know i've always been a nice guy but
it's the there's a difference between
being nice
and it's just
and the thing is a lot of the times
it's a religious person
i don't know what it is but somebody
who's religious but doesn't push it on
you
there's a that person a lot of times
always seems to be very happy
and and no one he never really hurts
anybody
so like that like every once in a while
i'm like should i be religious like
because they're always really positive
religious it gives you some type of
belief yeah
and it keeps you together i know a lot
of people disagree with me when it comes
to religion that's why i don't [ __ ]
talk about it it's my it should be your
own personal thing and it's your own
personal belief what you believe
and what keeps you going every day i
don't care what it is as long as you
have something it's the people who say
i'm atheist
and that doesn't bother me i don't give
a [ __ ] if you're right there none of
that [ __ ] when it comes to me i don't
give a [ __ ] if you vote you don't vote
or what your religion is because those
those topics always cause [ __ ]
problems
if it keeps me and you together as
friends i don't give a [ __ ] what your
anglers just don't push it on me yeah
you know just don't put there's only one
person who pushes the [ __ ] bible on
me and that's my niece
really she heard the podcast yeah
and she doesn't push it on me heavy she
just mentions it to me every once in a
while what did she say i don't know have
you read the king david side i don't
[ __ ] know you know
and she does it the cute way would you
get your nissan because every time you
talk about your niece i'm like
no my wife said no she's like don't put
her on because she's too young and then
the mother will listen to her and here
is talking about [ __ ] stabbing
[ __ ]
and she'll get upset why'd you put my
daughter on there so i gotta wait till
she turns 18. your niece is mad mercy
right oh yeah like a little like she's
like a big sister now well not really i
mean she's 18 she's 17 yeah when you're
17 you don't know what you know
it's tough to but she likes mercy and my
niece is very sweet and she said a
couple things
in the last year that has really made me
uh turn my head around at her because
she once and whatever we were talking
and she goes you know i want to
go back to school uncle joey i get a
degree so i can take care of you when
you get old
she said little things to me she's very
sweet my niece you know she grew up
without a dad
so
that hole is is there and she had
problems with somebody a couple years
ago at the church some guy
an older guy in her got into it and uh
she just you could see that she know
my wife she said something with dating
that destroyed me she was like i could
always tell that you were missing a mom
you just have that thing that you really
sing a mom yeah
she goes you just have that you it's it
makes you a different person she
explained it like what she meant she
told me when i was doing blow one night
she didn't know i was doing blow and it
just freaked me the [ __ ] out
it made me you know what because at
least she paid attention no other woman
had told me that you know
that's very interesting did you say what
it was that you she could tell she said
i was missing a mother's love
that there was something about me that
you could tell but that i was very sweet
but i could have been sweeter
lee [ __ ] say at the church
what's happening now get up
drink your coffee do a little [ __ ]
stretch stretch your back out stretch
your hands your feet get out there
[ __ ] it's a beautiful day to be
alive you're going to sit there with
your thumb up your ass life's against me
who gives a [ __ ] everybody's against you
but don't let them know just get up wash
your balls and get the [ __ ] out there
lee get out there lead [ __ ] get
out there so i walk down to the corner
where i live where there's been offices
all my [ __ ] life
in fact great drake used to have her
office in there that's how i found out
about him i walked down there to do
podcasts twice
something made me walk down there i
walked i pressed the buzzer
and i went in and the guy's name was
victor and i talked to him a little bit
he was at the funeral parlor across the
street rented all the four offices but
there's one office they're not sure
he was going to contact them today and
let them know it's got windows air
conditioning we have our own door to the
street we could smoke dope in there if
we want to yell and scream
yeah so we'll find there's two places
that has the outdoor it's like a hotel
oh no it's outside there were recovery
they were like redone hotels that's what
i want for the office i want windows i
don't want to be trapped like this this
anxiety [ __ ] box
there's no [ __ ] in there everybody wants
to put the head down to 74. when you
were in vegas you set the air condition
you notice it was [ __ ] lying to you
oh was it really yeah that's why you
sweat a [ __ ] night in vegas because
it said the 60 but it's really 89. uh
they don't [ __ ] put trump was cool i
don't i don't i didn't notice it there
but i [ __ ] i as soon as i get into a
hotel that's what i go for turn into the
coldest possible do you really i [ __ ]
love you
and they told 55. this ain't 55. you
want 55. i go down to 55 if i can
because some hotels are going down a
[ __ ] 50 they're really 60. they
always lie to you by 10 because they
don't want to spend the [ __ ] money
they want to save that's like like this
office we went to the other day like we
keep it at 74 all day this california
bits yeah
gonna do dick it's gonna be 90 in
[ __ ] july gotta turn that [ __ ] up to
[ __ ] 50.
what where were you i think maybe you
were in tennessee it was last year
because when i went to tempe it was an
older one where you couldn't do the
temperature but it's like high cool low
cool right i turned it to high cool i
left it for [ __ ] all day and i woke
up shivering oh yeah in arizona don't
[ __ ] around but you did it
you did it once i think your wife's
family and he started peeing on the
floor
i don't know i think he said it on stage
like once and it [ __ ] killed me for
months like you started like being
around the room from the bed i'm [ __ ]
around dog when it gets cold and i don't
want to get up that's what that's mean
to be [ __ ] cold in the middle of that
i love it
i love being like the only way i can
sleep is [ __ ] freezing yeah i like
putting the blanket on my head with that
sleep apnea tube flowing out like a
[ __ ]
over your head oh yeah oh that freaks me
out i can't do that i put the blanket on
my head and how i breathe is with the
sleep apnea tube
that's why i like it freezing i want to
do you put your foot out not even close
everything stays underneath oh i have to
have my foot i have at least have one
foot out and my head's always out ham
hock sticking out there god damn right
sticking like stinking like a pretty
soon there's gonna be someone maybe
wearing slippers i'm gonna wear my
yarmulke you ain't gonna win no [ __ ]
slippers homeless i'm gonna have to put
uh bring homeless to the new office
you're not bringing hummus to the new
[ __ ] office because i don't even want
home that's a no homozygous you know
where i heard here they have good hummus
where in your [ __ ]
austin texas they have no [ __ ] hummus
there they kill people
did you know that
they kill people who eat hummus
go to houston or dallas they'll kill you
i'll take you to midland you're gonna be
[ __ ] hummus and middle and so you
have a bullet in your [ __ ] head
before you even dip that chip in it'll
be like one of those kennedy bullets
that'll [ __ ] take you right
you just fall that's all you hit
and that makes you know you sleep in the
[ __ ] hummus you [ __ ] moment i'll
die happy we're only eating at two
places in [ __ ] austin papasitos okay
papados that's it i'm going to pop it
i'm going to stand in line for 12 hours
for that barbecue you're gonna go fetch
it yeah you're gonna go fetch it i'm
gonna give you like 50. you're gonna
you're gonna get nothing left i'm eating
all the brisket on the way back you can
stand online all [ __ ] day when you
get back just send me some potato salad
mac and cheese a little bit i love
telling you you're gonna live like a
doctor down there the [ __ ] papacitos
of papados is walking distance from the
hotel okay i don't play games that hotel
is great now do they have other stuff
besides seafood stuff or no i don't know
i don't ask questions you eat what they
[ __ ] give you they don't know no
restaurant just gives you anything
lobster and
i know they got lobster bits they got
nice crab and shrimp salad you don't
have a steak when i go to texas i'm
gonna have like [ __ ] i want to have a
steak maybe that's just honestly
i'm like i want if i ask for vegetables
they'd laugh at me and give me another
[ __ ] steak wait if i take you to
papasitos and you call the girls and
tell a [ __ ] you and your mom
wait i think of the papacy those and you
pick up the phone and go [ __ ] you and
your mom that ain't dick with you
[ __ ] cat food oh [ __ ] all right
will you [ __ ] serve me as cat
food what do you get papasitos
everything
with some [ __ ] rice and beans and a
salad
oh you're in texas [ __ ] this is
some tex-mex [ __ ] i'm gonna go to
chewie's
we're gonna get the elvis chicken on
wednesdays the elvis chicken on monday
it's the sour cream and whatever
enchiladas what are you [ __ ] nuts
nobody goes to chew i'm gonna buy you a
swirl margarita chewie's your little
[ __ ] you're gonna want to sniff a
girl's [ __ ] when i get through with
you you understand me
you have no you have no idea okay spooky
lives in texas spooky hooky spooky's
bringing one of her girls to fart your
[ __ ] mouth you're gonna take three
fights to the mouth in texas one a night
you don't even know these things yet
you're going for the full gummy bear
we're gonna put a wig on the floor
i did the full gummy bear once it was
the night out for the ahri that was the
worst you'll be fine you're as tough as
[ __ ] nails you understand me don't
don't worry about the goomy bears or the
sucky sucky bears or the [ __ ]
whatever i know you know it's just i
always think about that [ __ ] how come i
didn't get affected like that like i'm
sick and tired of hearing when i watch
this at msnbc yeah everybody always has
the same story that they come from a
broken home broken bone they come from a
broken well
it's obviously on your mind so let's
break it down broken home you didn't
come from a broken home i mean your mom
passed past but you always had the
people like you were never on this like
you were on the street but like you had
the benders and you had those people who
were there for you right so maybe they
just didn't have that
like i mean even though even though it
sucks like no one would want to have to
live
in the bender's basement or with the
runnings normally i'm on paper i live in
the bender's basement i have a nice
little [ __ ] bedroom air conditioning
and the cat yeah no no there was no
suffering okay i could lie to you and
tell you that you know oh my god i slept
in the basement roach is crawling on top
of me i'm not going to tell you that
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i never had
roaches crawling on top of me the worst
they got for me
was that night i snorted blow and woke
up next to the dog [ __ ] that's right
that's and that was bad in my eyes that
was bad but it's just uh
you know i saw juan
shoot that nico guy at 148th
and i always laugh about like i s
when i was eight i left the whole way
home i mean when you see your stepfather
shoot somebody
you're always like god damn you know
that this is tremendous when you see
your dad shoot somebody can you imagine
you see a little scene no little dicky
i'd shoot somebody at one of his [ __ ]
uh
and nobody called the cops and nobody
you know was that those type of days you
could shoot somebody and get away with
it nobody's going to call the cops on
you the people he sh even the guy he
shot never ratted him out that's the
word that's
that's what men do bro they go back with
a gun or they shut their [ __ ] mouth
and live with it
somebody shoots you at night you recover
that dude who shot you knows it's on
he's either gonna face the music
or he's gonna leave town
if he's got balls he's going to stay in
town and duke it out with you he shot
you already the words on the street he
shot you now it's your move people can
just look at you and go is he weak
why are you going to go back and shoot
him
so why didn't he go back and shoot him
because he was weak holy [ __ ] first of
all anybody who has the balls to shoot
you yeah you know there's no coming back
some people could tell you a [ __ ] sucker
some people could bit slap you some
people could hit you with their car
somebody who pulls out a gun and shoots
you
is at an all-time high of [ __ ]
craziness yeah craziness that's just
[ __ ] craziness you know why didn't i
get affected like i laughed the whole
way home i never told anybody that story
until i got into my [ __ ] 40s on stage
well uh one wasn't proud of it like he
always had guns around but like you said
when you went back you're like remember
when you shot that guy's like i have no
idea
no idea he would you know he wouldn't
cop to anything even if you caught him
so it wasn't like the guy who has
tattoos on his face it's like ones like
this guy's being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
gotta i gotta
i gotta stand up for myself but it's not
like he went over there to shoot the guy
one thing that juan stressed that i i'm
really
a fan of is one never wanted to let
nobody know his business
juan didn't have to let you know you
know when this guy died and had millions
of dollars
now he drive drove a maserati and wore a
suit every day he didn't like that
i got that quality from him you know i
look i i look at juan for a lot of
negative things i learned from him but
god damn he taught me a lot of positive
things you know it's like the guy who
talks money around me in front of me
[ __ ] irritates the [ __ ] out of me
somebody who brags that they did this so
they flew to [ __ ] europe you know
when somebody's telling your story and
you know when somebody's talking [ __ ]
and bragging
you know the difference when somebody's
dropping names or they're [ __ ]
dropping
uh money situations or what you know
one will you you couldn't get nothing
out of one the cars he drove were pieces
of [ __ ] the car he drove till he died
was the car he had when my mother died
no way yeah and he still had bullet
holes in it there was two little bullet
holes in the side a big
coronado cave el dorado cardinal i think
probably gets eight miles to the [ __ ]
gown so what did he do he just went home
and i encountered the money he went home
at night he lived when he died he lived
in the fourth store of an apartment
building that had no [ __ ] elevator
he would walk four floors every day at
76 [ __ ] years old
do you understand me but he did that to
keep himself sharp that was his way of
keeping himself sharp he knew that if he
moved they got to walk up those stairs
when i was a kid he was a big exercise
guy he was always doing calisthenics he
was always even at 50 he was always
doing something like that that's where i
get that from i try to uh shun him off
sometimes
because of my inner things i can't
believe he did those things to me after
my mother died but i learned a lot from
one and that was one of the lessons was
that empty barrels make the most [ __ ]
noise to keep your mouth shut
go in the back you don't have to show
people you have a cadillac you don't
have to show people a lot of money you
don't have to have all this [ __ ] you
know as long as you know you're the
baddest [ __ ] in the room that's
all that matters
i used to [ __ ] laugh at him how you
know but no i learned the lesson that he
didn't say nothing to you nothing he
never opened up his [ __ ] mouth but i
know by watching him and by how he
dressed and how he got ready to go out
at night then when he was in the room in
the back of his head he was the baddest
[ __ ] in the room
and he always had to [ __ ] prove if
it's if [ __ ] cracked up he rose to it
and that's why he shot that dude that
night i mean that
stays with me forever and do i love him
for it
i love him for the experience i love
for the balls of it he just had balls it
was over a [ __ ] statement
he shot this man over a statement and he
wasn't drinking he wasn't arguing he
just looked at the guy
went into the back room got a 45
and walked out there
and went and the guy was still talking
[ __ ] and he shot him in the [ __ ] leg
and we got in the car and he threw the
gun in the [ __ ] hudson river and we
went home and it's like he it's like it
never happened the next day it's like it
never happened i still remember eating
breakfast it's like it never [ __ ]
happened
we just ah you know it was just a bad
night we didn't discuss at the dinner
table like i said years later 20 [ __ ] 30
years later i brought it up to the guy
and he's like i don't know what you're
talking about and i [ __ ] died a
laughter i'm like this is why i love
this guy
this is the and that's who i am that as
much as i want to regret that i'm one in
a lot of ways i really am this should
have getting up early
this is taught to me by one and my
mother and i've been having summer
vacations in one summer one bought a
flower shop that's what he would do he
would just buy [ __ ]
like he would just buy a [ __ ]
business and learn about it as he went
and i remember him buying a flower shop
and him going i can't believe i could
only sell flowers in the flower shop so
he would get summer kids he would get
kids that needed jobs yeah me and him
would go into the city at four in the
[ __ ] morning four in the morning we
were seven
six eight
those ages in the summers instead of
[ __ ] around with my friends i'd go
with him pick up uh the live yolos the
long flowers and pick up roses okay
white ones long stems and then i had to
take them back at four in the morning i
had to de-stem them
okay you had a [ __ ] i learned how to
destroy roses when i was seven or eight
blah blah you know i had a that's the
work ethic this is why this [ __ ] doesn't
surprise me but this is what i want to
instill in my door this is why i always
take my daughter out first thing in the
daytime the show of the sun you gotta
get going
you gotta get going i wanna instill this
in you now because this is how it was
instilled in me you know pretty [ __ ]
interesting stuff how we we do get a lot
of stuff from our parents oh yeah that's
[ __ ] and you always fight it
but you really like i'm i'm my mom and
my dad it's just it's you can't fight it
but uh so did you sell the flowers like
did you did you go on the street corners
and sell them i think i did it once or
twice i was too young he had other guys
that went on 86th street in manhattan
and they would sell you they would
prepare bouquets and sell them tea i saw
that
in the early 70s done and i was and he
used to do it outside of banks
he would go as soon as they come out of
the bank
everybody's happy they want to buy
something so that's where they'll buy
flowers for their wife outside of the
bank that's
the happiest you are when you cast a
check oh yeah that's the happiest that's
when you cash when you get your [ __ ]
paper in your hand on a friday so he
would always go you got to catch him on
that [ __ ] happy this guy was criminal
this guy was in another jail how the
[ __ ] do you know how to market yeah you
know how to march common sense i i love
ever since i started putting the
pictures of the check on the receipt i
always get a receipt now
at the atm you can get a receipt with
the picture of the check on it
i'm like [ __ ] you i want to look at this
and what do you do you just look at the
check for a little while
paula made fun of me for [ __ ] days
when i had when i'm in vegas and i have
my little bankroll if i'm up i'll count
that [ __ ] all night i'll put in little
piles i'll count it i'm like i'll spread
it i'll do like a little fan
there's nothing i like more than playing
with money i love it
yeah that's why that's what it means to
be jewish [ __ ] yeah can't you wait to
get a million [ __ ] dollars and take a
bath with singles
and then take a bath with 50s and rub
them all over your [ __ ] in your
nutsack when i was really young my dad
worked in nightclubs and he was really
successful
and i remember i remember every day he
would like he would just have he never
had a wallet he would always have just
like the the
folded and my mom would go and he'd give
her like a couple hundred bucks to do
whatever she needed to do you have a
jukebank role they have a real
background i think he had a real one i
mean i never remember bankrolls three
hundreds over 100 singles to make him
look big no he
what he had was
to get into his nightclub dances it was
five bucks so he had like a thousand
five so usually
but uh it was just like
and he talks about it now is he he used
to carry thousands of dollars and
it's just it's not necessary but you
never feel better than when you have
like a full wallet it's it's [ __ ]
it's it's something that shouldn't
affect you
but just i don't know i don't know if
it's because i'm jewish or what but
[ __ ] i mean you don't you carry a
little bit of cash but everything now is
credit cards
when you know it's uh it's really weird
i like to have cash yeah because i know
about emergencies yeah that's right [ __ ]
up yeah you know i'm always scared that
there's an earthquake
and they knocked the central system off
the [ __ ] bank of america yeah on the
other bank and everybody's account goes
to zero what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do and that's
gonna happen there's somebody's gonna
come up with that scam and just go
this is it we're gonna [ __ ] the
bank systems and everybody's [ __ ]
money's gonna go back to zero i don't
wanna think about that we're not gonna
know how much money you really have
you're not gonna know you're gonna have
to go to the back and find them i had
seven hundred thousand dollars no you
didn't you know what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do lee
this is gonna happen someday it's gonna
happen here in l.a during an earthquake
yeah it could happen anywhere else
they're gonna blame it on an electrical
short or something that you don't see
this coming i see it coming well i built
my [ __ ] earthquake kit after the last
couple things i spent like 300 bucks
come on on amazon i have two kits now
one's in my car and one's at home what
do you got in the car i got a
i got a change of clothes i got pants
like something like gym pants i got
change underwear change of socks shirt i
got something that will cut my seatbelt
if it's the guy if i can't if it's
jammed or whatever
i got a water bottle
where is the the jammer
it's in my it's in the bag i actually
have to put the bag in my car they're
both sitting because i just built them
i got a water bottle with a filter
in it so i could always just pour water
into it if i needed to
i got a
a flashlight i got a bunch of d
batteries and then i just went on
and you don't know this nature valley
granola bars i bought about i bought a
box of like 96 i just put half in each
bag
and i'm just ready to go
you ready i [ __ ] if there's a big one
cause there's been a bunch of what about
nice ones you got a big [ __ ] round
you should probably get back you're not
thinking i got a big knife you might as
well get a gun too lee
oh you got a couple [ __ ] guns first
you know what i'm saying you're at that
age you need a [ __ ]
45 in a bazooka you're jewish you never
thought about having a [ __ ] bazooka
no you see those jews in israel with the
[ __ ] bazookas and [ __ ] that no one
wants your cousins no those are the
[ __ ] those are little [ __ ]
and [ __ ] there but i mean well israel
don't have bazookas with all the money
they got they're bazookas but they're
the people who are
throwing it over the borders or the
palestinians
[ __ ]
i don't want to talk about it because i
always get yelled at when i talk about
this [ __ ] but the palestinians yeah you
like them
no i i understand both sides are doing
the wrong thing
but i mean it's [ __ ] it's your home
team it's my home team is israel so i'm
gonna always support them more i i
understand both sides are [ __ ] up and
and they shouldn't be doing it but come
on you're sending missiles over the [ __ ]
if mexico was sending missiles over the
border you'd [ __ ] they'd [ __ ] do
stuff to mexico what happened to the
[ __ ] israel flag this is why this
office didn't work out cox i'm bringing
the first thing i do i'm gonna run the
[ __ ] flag with you
i told you from day one that the [ __ ]
flag was supposed to be it
oh yeah a little flat fee a little party
you shoot your pants no it wasn't [ __ ]
yes you did it's just a little drop
waiting i'm gonna sit here with [ __ ] in
my pants how the [ __ ] do you think i am
what's the matter with you
what would you do if you were sitting
there right now did that fart and a
little [ __ ] came out i would fly
well then i would throw my jeans in the
toilet and sit here [ __ ] naked for
the rest of the podcast i don't [ __ ]
know you know when you're gonna [ __ ]
when you're gonna fart you know you take
away i made a mistake a few weeks ago
no i don't want to take a word for this
this is real this is [ __ ] uh shrimp
cocktail
with a salad last night
oh i love some cocktail
but uh oh geez you smell it now no i'm
closing when i'm closing my nose on
purpose
you know i'm starting to smell more now
since i stopped smoking pot really that
makes sense i lost my sense of smell man
i can't believe i didn't smell a lot of
[ __ ] now i could smell [ __ ] in the house
i could smell cat piss
i could [ __ ] smell it for years my
wife was gonna smell that i don't
[ __ ] smell nothing yeah
i mean
it makes sense that it would burn your
nose hairs or something i'm not really
sure i don't know what happened i don't
know what the [ __ ] happened the sense of
smell just went the [ __ ] away man
i wish i i you know
i didn't know i don't [ __ ] know
nothing lee i'm not a doctor
now what you got to do is you got to try
to sniff an [ __ ] maybe you'll be on
my side no please that's essential
listen when you sniff an [ __ ] or you
go down with a woman everything your
senses all open up you're excited so you
sniff everything and that's the yeah but
if you have no sense of smell what am i
just sniffing a girl's ass that don't
smell like a little bit of [ __ ]
something to it that'd be amazing no
it's kind of you don't want when you eat
[ __ ] you want the smell like skin and
soap well no that's a little different
there's no [ __ ] where's that
[ __ ]
and that little [ __ ] dust comes out
you want that to have some weight
there's dust coming in i don't [ __ ]
know you're doing it wrong you have some
weight don't you
yeah well that's different there's no
[ __ ] coming out of there uh why are you
so sensitive about [ __ ] what's the
matter with you that's coming away [ __ ]
one day when you were a kid no i didn't
so then what's the problem with [ __ ] you
don't like eating [ __ ] nothing no i do
you're a nasty [ __ ] you know that
goddamn right
we uh we watched conair with ricky last
night and i love that dave chappelle and
your breath smells like [ __ ] he told me
he loved me
you ever seen that movie what kind of
connie yeah
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys
connor what's wrong with conor i don't
know i thought you guys would do
something different we did no we did a
new one we did we did uh bringing out
the dead i was bringing out that that's
a good [ __ ] bring out the dad's
[ __ ] that's a great [ __ ] movie i
haven't seen that in years did that get
good reviews no apparently it bombed the
bomb yeah yeah that's a good movie
oh you know what i'm doing tonight i'm
going to be like rivera's party oh [ __ ]
watering power downtown what are you
dropping names no he was on the podcast
i know and uh he called last night do
you want to go or you have a podcast
this evening i have a podcast what time
is your podcast seven that's what time
the thing is he's gonna have a movie and
food and he put all that name on the
tent oh [ __ ] and everything's [ __ ]
beautiful here who's this
what's up joey who's this
it's ed suarez there's my brother how
are you my friend
good how are you man you're just waking
up see i woke you up [ __ ] sucker
no no no i've been up
jumping up and down
uh baltimore's baltimore man you know if
you go two blocks away from where we're
at man i'm i'm scared really nervous
it's the [ __ ] wire 2014
jesus christ man
you know they shot somebody at the
comedy club there
did you know this guy they shot somebody
at the comedy club there that's how
[ __ ] what
baltimore doesn't [ __ ] around even
anderson silva would have a hard time in
[ __ ] baltimore when they shoot
somebody at a comedy club that's like
shooting somebody at [ __ ] disneyland
you know what i'm saying who goes to
disneyland to shoot somebody that's a
miserable [ __ ] who leaves a comedy
club and shoot somebody that happened at
that [ __ ] club there so that just
goes to and i don't i have no problems
with baltimore i think it's going to be
a [ __ ] great weekend
for fights and everything etc how the
[ __ ] are you a friend of the family i
don't see you no more we don't talk
ah man you know everything's good man
just been uh traveling quite a bit
lately you know we uh we had a big dogs
fight in abu dhabi and then now we got
glover's fight we had rafael dos anjos
fight this past saturday so we've had uh
april's been a busy month for us here
let me ask you this i know you you you
you flew home with uh
george
the other day your partner the most
interesting man in the world
he is the world's most interesting man
for sure let me ask you something what
type of deal do you have with american
airlines are you platinum express also
platinum whatever he was telling us well
no uh he's he's american i i'm united in
that are you really he told me he's
platinum something he doesn't even he
just all he has to do is call and they
don't even [ __ ] answer the phone they
know he gets a free plane ticket or
something
yeah no it's not it's not uh he doesn't
get a free ticket but he gets that
upgraded actually he's got that platinum
status on uh american and i have uh the
the 1k status on united
1k [ __ ] i i'm so far away from you guys
and i fly every weekend that's that's
cause you fly to brazil in london in
dubai and [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] travel in
this [ __ ] country that's it
yeah on united last year i hit a million
miles so
now i'm i'm i'm a premier executive for
life
oh my god
a million miles on one year jesus christ
listen man
you and your partner george is some of
the or probably the best management team
in mma you guys have uh lyoto and
anderson and glover and rafael and you
know you got your little brazilian mafia
there and a couple white guys that's
that's the name of your model the
brazilian mafia and a couple of white
guys
and uh it's no it's no mistake you know
you guys are champions i mean i've loved
you since i met you you're a successful
dude
uh what's going on with anderson silva
these days i see him [ __ ] hitting the
muay thai punching bag he looks
beautiful
no he's doing good i actually spoke with
him last night he he's feeling good uh
um yeah he's training um i mean he's
doing really i haven't seen him in
probably about a good six weeks
um when i uh when i uh
when i got back in town or actually he
was out of town and then right when he
got back in town i had to leave down
again so i'll probably be hooking up
with them uh on monday we're probably
gonna have breakfast when um i get home
on sunday from baltimore hopefully with
uh with that uh light heavyweight title
around wolver's uh waste jesus christ
this is gonna be a great [ __ ] fight
you know i don't even know who else was
on the card but it doesn't even matter i
i watched the uh end of uh
the the whatever show last night the
countdown show i didn't even know phil
davis
and anthony johnson i don't even know
anthony johnson was back in the ufc
that's how busy i've been lately i'm
like you
and i didn't know tim bush was fighting
luke brockwell but it doesn't matter
compared to jon jones glover i mean the
guy's won 20 fights in a row i mean you
can see he's not [ __ ] around
uh now he's focused man i was with him
yesterday man he's very focused very
relaxed very confident you know he's uh
he's had this guy he's got his eye on
this prize for a long time and
he's just looking forward to getting in
there saturday night and uh
trying to take that belt back with him
you know uh one thing i love about i
mean this is just such a [ __ ] perfect
fight
this couldn't be written any better the
styles you know i can't wait to see you
know jon jones is a wrestler he takes
this [ __ ] down this guy could
[ __ ] submit you you know that's a
difference yeah i mean vidor could say
mitch i mean vito almost had jon jones
i'm sure that
you guys were looking at that tape and
whatnot but this guy's jiu jitsu and
he's a big guy and he's strong
you know i'm going to be sitting it was
very good i mean he uh he made it to i
think he got third place in abu dhabi a
few years ago from namaste no that's
what i'm saying i didn't even know he
was an abu dhabi guy till about a month
ago i looked at his i mean this guy you
know when you go to abu dhabi you got to
bring it and uh jon jones has had a lot
of accomplishments but abu dhabi does
something to you jiu-jitsu it does
something to your confidence
it's like me getting hbo special you
know you just it just bumps you up a
level you know
so i know that uh
i mean i know that jon jones has gone up
against every [ __ ] formidable
opponent
in the 205 division
i mean i mean he's definitely a very
complete fighter you know he uh you know
glover is um he's a guy who uh he's got
good boxing skills he's got heavy hands
um he's got good wrestling
um and uh and his jiu jitsu is very good
so you know he's definitely a complete
fighter he he's trained and he's
prepared to take the fight wherever it
goes so uh i think i think it's going to
be a great fight man you know once again
you can't disregard
you know jon jones for his
accomplishments i mean
is going to be his seventh title defense
i believe so i mean you know that that's
the record as for a light heavyweight
champion so you definitely can't uh you
know underestimate his accomplishments
but uh but i think lover is uh you know
prepared and enough for the battle
no this is uh
and it's funny now he trained at
america's top team if you watched the
ufc last week america's top team
did very well and uh i i know that
there's the black house chairman
america's top team you have all these
it's funny when when i started watching
ufc the big camp was iowa you know
yeah exactly it was uh noah pitch
fighting militants fighting systems and
and aka was very big when i got into it
you know uh they had the this is before
kane you know when they just had [ __ ]
chick
uh the one kid and john quick swear my
quick swig
and now the tide has changed it's uh
it's pretty much greg jackson's and uh
an american top team i mean and that's
why he trained at american top team but
he's still with with uh
uh
john up in the kempo place right he's
still gonna yeah yeah well yeah
he did his last um he did his last
couple camps at american top team but
you know glover's kind of uh
a little bit of a nomad he travels
around a little bit you know he likes to
train that black house he he really
likes california um you know the guys at
the american top team are just a great
set of guys over there he's got good
training there
um but i know deep down that he really
likes california and eventually i think
he'll probably be making most of his
camps out in california he just likes
the the weather better he just likes he
just likes california a lot better isn't
lyoto out here also now
what do you say is lyoto in california
training also
oh yeah yeah leota leota trains out of
la too yeah we're trading the black
house you know it's amazing that if you
live here and train here i mean you
cannot lose if you really there's no
excuses
there's no i mean there's there's such
an abundance of training in in southern
california i mean from you know the top
people in the world in the ground i mean
you can get great boxing and get great
moon time i mean there's just there's
just a lot of options for for a
professional fighter in southern
california from los angeles to san diego
i mean there's just
it's pretty much a hotbed of martial
arts
just in my neighborhood just in the
neighborhood where i run in hollywood
justin fortune is back with pacquiao now
i think now he's got miguel cotto back
over there or somebody else at the gym i
heard from michael foley
just if you were in hollywood you could
do your strength and conditioning at
justin fortunes which is on
sunset and gardener or sunset in sierra
bonito then you get in your car and you
go a half a mile of [ __ ] cabrinis
where verdum is at and [ __ ] uh babalu
and then from there you go to [ __ ]
the boxing guy right up the corner is
[ __ ] uh
pacquiao's boxing guy that little gym oh
i wrote rose that's in the [ __ ]
that's in a two-mile radius
that's not talking about tenth planet
that's not talking about gracie baron
and whatever that's not talking about
black house
yeah and then you start moving south and
then you've got you know you've got
black house and in the south bay then
you've got the gr of course the gracies
right there in torrance and you've got
uh um king's mma then you've got mark
munoz who's down at rain
uh then he's got alliance down in san
diego right alliances in san diego i
mean it's just not even if you look up
here i'm in the valley
and the valley you could train at vinnie
curtis place for your hands and you
could shoot over the john jock all
within
it's all within a few miles yeah i mean
the valley and then where
and then and then the valley they got
that glendale uh train where ronda
rousey
around burgers train in there too it's
it's it's something to you know i live
down the block from the the hall of fame
museum
uh who's the benny the jet
we're right around the corner
that's cool my office right now our
office for the church is right around
the corner from benedict school
that that's how [ __ ] clever benny the
[ __ ] jet teaches kickboxing two
blocks from here
the old i don't know
i'm maybe 150 yards from gold court
that's where it all started you know
we're 150 yards
right in that area yeah they have the
the black belt hall of fame the
right from walking distance from where i
live
is valley martial arts supply
that's where gokore goes in the
afternoons and asks what's his name jean
labelle is in there in the afternoons
that's the oldest martial arts supply
school in [ __ ] california bruce lee
used to go there
right there on lancashire boulevard it's
a little school next to it it's a little
shop next to a kenpo school where they
don't teach they don't teach they teach
in spanish at suarez that's how [ __ ]
that's how different the valley is the
guy teaches in spanish only ken bocarade
he's one of ed parker's guys
but he's a mexican dude and just teaches
it's amazing
it's amazing what's available to you now
if you really want to fly through the
[ __ ] air and beat people up in the
octagon that's why i was
that's it man and la's a spot to do it
you still been training at suarez
nah man i i i don't train hardly ever
once in a while i'll i'll put a guy on
and go train at the gracies but not very
often you look good you're looking
you're looking thin you look good i saw
you in the countdown show with your man
uh glove and you look good you look
healthy
oh well thanks man
no you gotta you got a busy [ __ ]
summer you also got
machida fighting our boy
yeah we got that we got marquita
fighting wideman um
and you know and on top of that we got
the rfa you know we got our next rfas
gonna be in um
june 6th in la
and then it looks like you know we've
got
just this summer uh june we've got two
rfa events july we got one in august we
got one so what four events over a three
month span there for the rfa too on top
of all the fights now let me ask you
this rfas where's uh where are the ones
in june because i know you have them i'm
out of town but i like to go to one of
them and sit there and [ __ ] around with
you for yeah
yeah june uh june 6th is going to be in
culver city i'm at the veteran's
memorial okay i'm in utah that weekend
where else
okay and then june uh 27th
right now it looks like we're going to
be going to
either st louis
or possibly utah we're just looking
around for uh june 27th and then uh july
25th will be in denver
and then uh looks like august 22nd uh
most likely we're going to be coming
back to um
coming back to los angeles again okay so
i'll leave that date open so i go down
there and [ __ ] around with you guys
that's amanda what's up now this rsa
what kind of league is this is it still
an octagon or
yeah it's still an octagon then that you
know basically we're you know the the
developmental organization for the ufc
we went out there and we licensed the
octagon because i wanted to kind of
emulate and get these guys prepared to
move up into the
ufc as you know as best as possible and
uh and we're actually doing a pretty
good job of it i mean last night i was i
was counting how many guys we've put in
the ufc we've done about 14 shows and i
believe we've put 13 guys in the ufc
jesus christ
i mean listen your management team you
know
is a champion management team
you guys have had champions in a couple
different weight divisions uh what does
it entail to be a man a good manager let
these people know what
i mean obviously you got the best ed
yeah i you know what at the end of the
day man i i believe you just you just
got to be solid man you got to be a man
of your word and and you know when guys
are looking for management you got to
trust your management you know i mean i
think i think at the end of the day you
have to have that sort of a relationship
it's a lot of hard work you know people
say what do you do as a manager i mean
it's almost kind of like
it's almost easier to say what we don't
do i mean you know it goes from i mean
you name it as a manager we do it you
know i mean from
you know
everything from personal stuff to to to
business stuff to coordinating their you
know you know help coordinate their
training where they're gonna train up
you know when when they when they travel
abroad
to uh to train you know all the
logistics i mean it's a lot of things
and then we're talking about negotiating
contracts going out there and looking
for sponsors and
and and a lot of our fighters are being
foreign fighters when when they come to
the united states it's much different
than having you know
an american fighter here and you know
you could send them you know the guy has
a fight in the ufc
you send to the ufc he does all that but
we kind of have to uh be there by their
side help translate for them and kind of
navigate them through the weekly
obligations that
that come up when you're uh fighting on
a show like the ufc
now do you guys manage uh ciao magalis
he fought
atlanta no no we don't manage him but
he's really good friends with uh he's
really good friends with uh glover and
he's a good friend of ours but we don't
actually manage him now he fought last
week
and yeah he looked good oh my god and he
it was the saddest thing from
a different perspective because the guy
he fought
[ __ ] up he made his family come
they put on t-shirts
they brought the baby
they had a headband on the baby the
whole neighborhood was there
and that child muggle east came out like
a [ __ ] cannonball
i mean that's all i could do well you
came out like a savage yeah it came out
like a [ __ ] savage that they you like
when you go for your unemployment check
on the fifth or your welfare check it
when you leave that office you're going
to stab a [ __ ] because you
already had plans you had the crack pipe
ready
yeah
that [ __ ] they must have told
them something like they must have
whispered in his ear this guy wants to
[ __ ] your girlfriend in the ass because
he came out of there and just punched
this guy
and this guy i think what i think what
they told them is they said man if you
don't win this fight you're going to end
up uglier than you already are oh my god
there's no plan hey he said there's no
way in hell i can do that and he went
out there and knocked the dude's head
off he came out and he had the guy he
punched him and i felt so bad for the
guy because then the guy kept looking at
his family
he was so embarrassed for them he kept
thinking like why did i bring him here
to get watch me get beat up but the
funny thing was like his brother was a
redneck and he kept yelling at the ref
ref he still had a chance why'd you stop
it well because your [ __ ] guy was
getting punched in the [ __ ] head 50
[ __ ] times he saved his life take the
beat and go home and enough next time
don't get [ __ ] shirts
now you got to walk out of the arena
with those shirts on and your boy
[ __ ] got beat up that's why i don't
wear [ __ ] shirts [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
a lot of pressure man i've i've never
had to do that but i'm imagining that
would be a lot of pressure man to walk
out of your hometown and fight on on a
stage like the ufc i mean i i would
think you know i guess it just depends
where you look at it but but i mean it
would be nice to have that a little bit
of a hometown advantage but i would also
think that the pressure
would would escalate
quite a bit you know knowing that you're
fighting in your hometown with you know
all your friends and family there
watching your lives
i don't know like i said i've never
fought so i couldn't tell you what it
feel like but i'm just imagining it
would probably be uh pretty intense you
know you know the other morning when we
got on the plane with george and redem
and
a bunch of people on the plane
just about when i went to sit down joe
rogan looked over at me real quiet and
he goes
i would never want to be a [ __ ]
fighter
you know and i didn't even ask him why
i just put my earphones and thought
about it and uh
you have no idea this you know i read a
bunch of articles about people
bad-mouthing like gsp you know
because of his decision to step away and
whatever personal problems he had and
it's they have no idea
i bet you
the first time anderson lost that time
when he got in the car at one point he
goes thank god it's over
thank god that yeah this pressure
it does i mean it's um you know people
have no no idea this sort of pressure
then they have no idea what sort of
pressure because at the end of the day
this sport is a very cruel sport for the
fighters you know um you know you you
you know you look at a guy and and you
know he gets knocked out and it's the
worst feeling in the world but you know
it's almost like that thrill because you
know you know that every time you walk
into that octagon you know you have a
chance to to make history you have a
chance to to have an incredible fight
you have the potential of that and and
when you do
it's one of those greatest feelings in
the world you know i mean i mean i i
like i said i've never thought that i've
made that walk so many times with
anderson and with lyoto with nogueira
with all the guys that i've that i've
made that walk with and i've had some
incredible moments you know i mean when
i when i look back at my career as a
manager i sit back and i think wow man i
mean some of the most um you know some
of the most memorable moments in mixed
martial arts being on on the good side
and on the bad side i've been involved
with uh with anderson silva knocking out
rich franklin with with uh you know
nogueira submitting tim sylvia with with
lyoto knocking out um rashad evans but
i've also been on some of the most
devastating moments when you know
anderson breaking his leg uh the way he
broke it um things like that so you know
i've had i've been on one side of the
fence and i've been on the other and uh
you know and and people
people can say what they want but until
you're right there in that moment um you
know it's it's uh it's it's a pretty
intense feeling you know it's really
weird uh
he also made a statement to me that when
we sat down and i i got mad the other
day with me and lee lee's the co-host
say hello eduardo yeah
we were talking about how's it going
rogan said that when he does comedy
and he gets in his car that the twitter
is very positive that when he does a
podcast and he gets in his car that the
twitter feed is very positive
he goes i hate doing the fights because
the night after the fights i get a
thousand tweets of people calling me a
[ __ ] or saying that i i said something
wrong that i favored this guy
and one thing i've always hated and is
people who get so involved in sports
you know it's like i was in boston i'm
at the bar i just took 200 pictures
with people and some guy comes up to me
hey man you had herb dean on the show
how can you do that
that guy is making the worst call i'm
like oh whoa it's a [ __ ] saturday
night
and i could tell this guy had been
thinking about this for three weeks
he had been thinking about this for
three weeks you know i looked at him the
first night are you a fighter oh no i'm
just a fan you know jesus [ __ ] christ
don't you owe [ __ ] money on your
credit cards
go [ __ ] pay him that's what you
should be worried about the [ __ ] are you
worried about whether herb dean made a
good call i watch a fight it's over it's
[ __ ] over you know i can't imagine
but those are the people that drive me
[ __ ] crazy when i put on the twitter
and there's people saying look at
[ __ ] new england they picked this guy
in the third round they suck are you
[ __ ] serious i guarantee you got a
wife with a tremendous [ __ ] and you're
worried about the [ __ ] new england
patriots third-round draft pick
and then you're probably completely
wrong about what the [ __ ] you're saying
there's better things to worry about in
this world but unless you walk the steps
who the [ __ ] are you to [ __ ] open
your [ __ ] mouth about anderson silva
or b.j penn or or the only thing i get
mad at about fighters is when they don't
go in there and even if they lose they
fought their heart out when [ __ ]
machida lost uh jon jones he still beat
that's the only round jon jones ever
lost correct
well he's progressive yeah yeah and then
oh until then yeah that's augustine but
machida made a [ __ ] statement he
didn't go in there and do the same [ __ ]
he does gets winded
you know that's when i get mad at a
fighter when you know the same way if
you came to see me yet after a year i
was saying the same [ __ ] joke you go
joey nothing happened in your life in
the last year that you still have the
same [ __ ] 20 minutes nothing happened
so that's i just want to fight it to
evolve every time i see machida he
evolves
every time i see johnny ray he evolves
every time i see [ __ ] anderson he
evolved that's the only quantum i have
and that's what i've learned from mma
that's what made me a better comedian
because i'm like that [ __ ] guy is
fighting again with that same [ __ ]
move
he's going for that same one leg that
hasn't worked in 20 [ __ ] years that's
what he worked on during the last eight
week training camp so i know he hasn't
worked that's the only time i get mad
when i see that the lack
and sometimes you know these guys work
on all these new things and and then all
of a sudden you know the old i ever give
those types and i said everybody has a
plan and then they get hit in the face
and that sometimes happens too you know
a guy's a wrestler the guy's arrested
he's working on his stand-up skills but
the minute he gets rocked he's going to
go back to what he knows and that's
wrestling you know and sometimes that
happens too but that's the great thing
about this sport is that you never
really know what can happen you know the
only guarantee is that there's no
guarantees and you move left when you
should have moved right and it's going
to be a [ __ ] short night for you and
that's what makes it all the [ __ ]
excitement in the world
exactly that that's what's exciting
about it is that you know at the end of
the day
you know i remember uh before her dream
fight against travis brown i was
watching it from home and it said that
85 of the fans uh thought that uh
that um travis brown was going to win
that fight
85
you never seen a bookie with a part-time
job right there you call your book you
can go lay everything i got on [ __ ]
redome because the general public is
wrong 70 of the [ __ ] time how's that
one for you that's the easiest way you
want to gamble just go on twitter and go
who does everybody like tonight and when
they all lean to travis brown go i'm
betting the other way even if you just
take a chance for 50 bucks because i
knew somebody was going to lose i didn't
know
i thought i thought cowboy was going to
have a hard night he fought a great
fight
i thought that uh you know i knew that
the the carmouche misha tate fight i
almost fell asleep three times and
usually i'm sitting there waiting for
misha's [ __ ] [ __ ] to pop out this
time i fell asleep from the [ __ ]
boring fest you know misha tate's got
somebody i love the debt she's a great
fighter but jesus christ
she's got the best body in the [ __ ]
world i wouldn't mind you know i don't
want to say yeah
no
yeah it was uh
that fight was a little bit uh and you
know and a lot of people were
complaining about that decision they
were thinking that uh
that luther much won that fight um you
know i i i have to go back and and i
have to watch
the first try i thought carmouche won
the first round for sure i thought the
second round could have went either way
and i thought the third round
third round was definitely misha tate so
it was one of those things where you
know that's what happens when you leave
it in the judge's you know
hand sometimes you don't get the the
knob that you were hoping for i even
read on google that misha tate thought
she lost
misha that misha
the reason why i don't i didn't watch
the misha tape fighter was because i had
people getting up i was sitting at the
end i had those joe rogan tickets that
are tremendous but i had people getting
up every [ __ ] thing to get alcohol
then they get up to pee in between the
fights i don't even know why they went
to the [ __ ] fight for
so finally during the misha tape fight i
said [ __ ] it i walked upstairs and i sat
at the bar and i
watched the [ __ ] last fight from
there because
once that last punch is thrown i'm out
of it i don't want to get stuck on the
bottom flooring place you know so i got
the [ __ ] out of it really eduardo's i
will see you at the weigh-in
all right we'll be there and you have a
you have a show friday night friday
night i think it's sold i'm not sure but
uh listen man you're one of my favorite
people in the world and uh i don't see
you much and i don't talk to you much at
times we talk on the phone
but i'm always really proud of you and i
and i like you and your man you know
your partner came up to me the other day
because we walked to the plane together
we lost rogan and we walked the plane
together and i got to get something to
eat because i don't know if the planes
the food's going to be good so i got a
cuban sandwich and i went to get them
they had all this cuban stuff and i
wanted to get georgia cuban coffee ooh
and the people had no [ __ ] cuban
coffee i couldn't believe that cute so i
started talking to a lady in spanish
asking him when i got away george's eyes
were huge he goes
you talk spanish very good why aren't
you an announcer for bellator or
something like i can't [ __ ] i got no
good eyes i can't see nothing
but it's amazing when i talk spanish in
front of people they lose their [ __ ]
mind they think that only
bad words come out of my mouth and also
i'm dealing with the [ __ ] oh yays and
that
but
that's it it's always a pleasure
to be around [ __ ] winners brother
well that's it man
in this in this world especially us
living in california you got to be able
to speak spanish right bro if you don't
know how to speak spanish in this world
you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] up in the next 20 years
you've got to teach your kids arabic and
russian you know it was funny in school
man
i never opened my spanish book man
because i spoke portuguese so most of
the time 95 of the time when the teacher
said how do you say that if i didn't
know i'd say it in portuguese and she
says yeah that's close enough that's
good it's amazing
i heard spanish is fairly easy for me
when brazilians say coward it's kovaji
you know and and it's so similar because
in spanish it's god
you know it's the same [ __ ] it's like
when you listen to somebody sicilian
when you're spanish
and you hear a sicilian talk you got
this [ __ ] because every three
words is a spanish word la cancionette
it's a [ __ ] song
is a song conscious is a [ __ ] italian
song so it's it's amazing when you know
spanish and you hear sicilians talking
you know every third word you pick it up
it's the same thing with brazilians when
they're around me
i could always pick up three or four
[ __ ] words here or there
but uh yeah
it it it seems like i you know like i
said i spoke portuguese first and it
seems like a little bit of an easier
transition from speaking portuguese and
trying to pick up spanish like for
instance i could speak spanish pretty
good when i go to mexico but like
sometimes if i'm watching like a spanish
television
sometimes i'll get lost because they're
speaking too fast and
and i can't understand everything but
you know portuguese i i understand
everything fluently but spanish tvs
sometimes you know all
all get a little bit lost when they
start speaking real fast so in other
words you could buy valiums in mexico
but i can never put you on spanish
jeopardy
exactly you'll never be on [ __ ]
mexican jeopardy
it's fast you gotta when you watch
telemundo you gotta pay attention
i don't think i'll be on any jeopardy
especially not in spanish
i love you ed suarez with all my heart
uh i'll be there with you i'm wishing
you all the best with glover i mean if
anybody deserves it he's a sweetheart of
a [ __ ] guy
sweetheart of a great guy man
sweetheart
man you know when you shake his hand you
can't even believe he's a fighter i mean
that's how sweet he is until you look at
his [ __ ] ears
you he has this weird warmth and you
know what's funny because i've been
reading now how
you know chuck says he's going to knock
out whatever and then uh uh jon jones
answered back you know
whatever whatever his name is i missed
that [ __ ] fighting do you know
that
i missed you chuckled i [ __ ] miss him
my favorite has always been anderson
silva but a tight second has always been
chuck liddell he's the reason why i went
to kenpo karate
i love chuck ledell i love everything
and i you know i would see him for years
i would never say a [ __ ] word to him
never never and then one time him and i
got put in a weird predicament and i
just told him how i felt
and now he always says hello i always
told him that
i had your poster on my [ __ ] wall for
a few months [ __ ] and he looked at
me and giggled and uh
i missed chuck liddell so hopefully
he'll be at the fight too jumping up and
down
i'll see you oh man i'll see machida
there hopefully all the boys are there
my friend
yeah actually machito when she was
actually taken off to brazil he had to
go uh he had to go do uh there's a um
uh
uh
arnold uh trade show out there for uh
supplements um rio so he has to go out
there to make an appearance for his
supplement company sponsor jesus [ __ ]
christ no machida in baltimore now i
don't feel safe no more
you know what i'm saying
it was i know black people won't [ __ ]
with me because black people love karate
you know what i'm saying
yeah black people love karate so they
love you [ __ ] walk around with a
cheetah black people like whoa
don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
i love you i'll see you uh thursday
night we'll get i'll call you as soon as
i hit the hotel
all right
thank you for calling in brother good
luck this saturday i love you
hey man take care i love you guys too
man take care
there you go
[ __ ] great guy man very lucky to have
him and uh
it's true man sometimes if you hang out
with people like that you get little
things from them like in the sense of
yeah you can't lose when you hang out
with people like that when you have
people like that around you i've called
that a thousand times and asked them for
advice even like hollywood advice
because management is management mm-hmm
you know it's it's the it's it's you
care
you care the extra mile so he's i've
called him he doesn't know the answer
he's calling me two days later with a
[ __ ] answer
you know he's probably had to contact
his attorney paid 200 out of his pocket
but he's done me the favor so
i have the utmost respect for a good
manager him and his partner are [ __ ]
great and i wish uh i like john jones i
like john jones personally i love him i
mean i'm not saying nothing bad about
him i think this is going to be a great
fight i think everybody should [ __ ]
watch it that's how i feel yeah about
you coxswain a million miles in a year
that's five million [ __ ] miles that's
george clooney type [ __ ] yeah that's up
in there oh my god let me give you some
shout outs real quick up in the air all
right okay go for it okay
ivan b i love you [ __ ] shane plan
b who loves you renee dillon robert
bueno lance armstrong junior girardo
ramirez darren jones edgar lawyer you
[ __ ] sucker
my favorite puerto rican roberto happy
birthday whatever the [ __ ] it is in your
life today also i want to give a shout
out to one of my favorite sponsors of
all time on itonic.com go check out on
it you want to get healthy go check out
on it i'm going to give lisa mouth for
brain today for his walk so you got to
smoke some dope i'm going to give you a
joint i'm going to get you a little
joint i want you to roll a joint okay
take a line and take two hits like this
and then put it out and then go for your
walk okay and you're gonna call me and
go joey i love you i just thought of 18
[ __ ] things because between the sun's
positive energies you walking
making positive for yourself and the
reefer you can't lose bring some water
with you
and every day you got your ipod right
got it you got your phone you got those
jews jumping up and down oh yeah they
should motivate you and then after a few
four weeks of walking you're gonna walk
four times a week this week that should
go okay four days yeah one with paula
i'm not seeing her this weekend sadly
when you get up no more [ __ ] denny's
we gotta go for a 30-minute walk then we
walk to denny's okay get everybody
involved we make this a family can show
them that show her that you're walking
and she'll say to you first leave what's
wrong with you and then she don't want
to go you go by yourself mm-hmm and they
know that you're the man oh you'll be
proud of me she's going to [ __ ] lana
del rey and i said have fun with your
cousin you going well she's going to the
same concert but in l.a this time i said
have fun with your cousin she's going to
stand out there for 12 hours
she's going to get there 10 in the
morning that poor girl she loves it i
have i couldn't do it you're like this
isn't that no your car's not bringing
you water that's what i said i said i'll
pick up afterwards for dinner
no no just bring them water online get
out of there bring them water i got
those two it's ecstasy get my head
accidental and jump up and down where's
the [ __ ]
oh what's the name of the chicks he's
gone lana del rey jesus that's [ __ ]
crazy oh jesus tweet
hours like i'm standing outside
12 [ __ ] before yeah
all right honey.com
maybe you should give her some [ __ ]
alpha brain
and maybe she won't stand online for 12
hours
uh honest.com go over there they got the
shroom tech they got the alpha brain
they got the strong bone
they got so many products they got the
digestive enzymes the papaya to help you
[ __ ] digest proteins they have to
enforce protein just give honor a shot
let it go into your life one [ __ ]
time and i guarantee you'll build they
got a money-back guarantee if you want
me to sit here and break down the
mushrooms and the amounts and the sodium
i got no [ __ ] idea what i do know is
it works go to honor.com i'll go to
joeydears.net look at my [ __ ]
schedule i added vegas on there july
18th with steve simone go to honor.com
go to joeydears.net look at the honor
what do you put in there church you get
10 percent off to that uh on it stay on
it program they mail them to your house
directly on the first of every [ __ ]
month you're gonna leave the house you
know put up with that [ __ ] it's like
dollar shave club
let me tell you something i shaved
yesterday morning with dollar shave club
again and as i was doing it i was like
jesus [ __ ] christ
jesus [ __ ] christ this is smooth and
it's the weight you know when you buy a
plastic one yeah i can't really control
it it's the weight of that handle that i
[ __ ] it's like having a dumbbell
[ __ ] shaves you so close but that's
not why you get everybody has a good
razor i'm not gonna lie to you the
norelco they all have a good razor you
know what the difference is dollar shape
from delivers them to your [ __ ] house
that's customer service that's what we
talk about you can get the one dollar
program the six dollar program or the
nine dollar program a month from nine to
[ __ ] for a year is what nine times
twelve whatever the [ __ ] it is uh twelve
times one dollar is [ __ ] twelve
dollars a year to shave that's you're
not paying
time is of the essence i'm 51. i don't
want to spend it in traffic you're
hitting that's my [ __ ] solution time
is everything why not have to raise it
deliver to your house you want to go to
some pharmacy and stand online [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you got better [ __ ] to do go to
fuckingjoeydays.net
go to the dollar shave club box and
press church boom there you go church
c-h-u-r-c-h you're going to get the best
races on the market delivered to your
[ __ ] house you don't have to leave
the house hulu plus [ __ ] again
i got to go through this [ __ ] with you
people i got to go through this [ __ ]
where you get 7.99 a month 7.99 a
[ __ ] month two weeks for free not one
week like when you go on the web page
two weeks gratis i'm the [ __ ] arm go
to hulu plus and press what joey joey
j-o-e-y you get the best [ __ ] shows
on there you can binge watch you could
take the day off your bigger weed and
watch everything all in one day from
[ __ ] uh
whatever
daily show the [ __ ] family guys
guys everything and hulu plus with the
emphasis on plus [ __ ] also
the best naturesbox.com
50 off 50 [ __ ] percent off your first
order let me tell you what gives you
half off who gives you a half off let me
tell you what you order the first shot
get the plantains get the spicy [ __ ]
uh pistachio pistachios get the black
and white granola make sure you get the
cocoa almonds and get what else did you
like the bagel sticks boom there you go
go try that that ain't good [ __ ] you
hit me up and
don't [ __ ] with me today huh
naturesbox.com is also on joeydears.net
what are you pressing the box brother
chilly joey j-o-e-y 50 off your first
order and then if you want that stuff
every month nutritious [ __ ] delicious
and yummy for your [ __ ] tummy
you understand me you show up with a bag
of [ __ ] pretzels or somebody's house
you show up you just take your dick out
and get ready for some yum yum juice
that's how you do it break your hand one
day i don't give a [ __ ] nailed it
life.com for all your vapor pen needs
you understand me mention vape mention
the church joey diaz will ever get ten
per minute
makes the [ __ ] vape thing go to
[ __ ] 40 dollars if you see gumi's
romano's out of [ __ ] weed stuff do
yourself a favor and hail that
[ __ ] it's the best 250 milligram
gummy out there for the [ __ ] money
maybe just half the green horn is
tremendous the 70 milligram green hornet
i'll put it up against a lot of [ __ ]
things i got to tell you i think the 200
milligrams of bpt's is what really
[ __ ] kills you with the green hornets
but nail the life.com go to their
webpage these guys are my [ __ ]
brothers you understand they're not in
business to beat nobody and make a
tremendous [ __ ] pen you could put the
wax in there or smoke the [ __ ] vapor
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do we got
you covered right here in the church of
what's happening now
did you get you to talk to a portuguese
person more often you're all fired up
i've been fired up it's wednesday you
know wednesdays i don't like people
before you please monday you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you should be
motivated on your own by wednesday your
positivity levels go down you know you
got bad news somebody [ __ ] you
somebody did this somebody did that so
wednesday and your next little extra
push that's what i'm here to give you
who gives a [ __ ] you go out there the
same way you went out there on monday
and let [ __ ] roll over your head let
them know you're gonna knock their wig
off and come on their [ __ ] bald head
if they [ __ ] with you that's how we do
it hillary say at the church so you need
to start wearing my hat now
you should start wearing a hat now i
don't want to
you know you never [ __ ] rub come on
your head woman's coming
no don't see them rubbing on your head
that's that's better than that [ __ ] that
grows here
you finger bang a chicken when it leaks
onto your hand
that little juice you massage on your
hand
and you hit your little bald spot there
and a week you look like [ __ ] michael
jackson you'll have head coming off a
merry orifice you understand me oh what
are you looking around for i'm not
looking around what do you got going on
today what are you doing today gotta
[ __ ] go home and
deal with his packing and stuff now and
then i got a joshua you're not gonna
pack today because you ain't moving
right now so you're going for a walk
first oh yeah let's put the immediate in
the front you don't you're not leaving
for a week if even if you get an
apartment a week so relax the first
thing i do go home is go home have a
nice little [ __ ] breakfast a little
protein shake or something did you use
yeah the juice and then go for a nice
little half 20 minute walk
30 minute walk clear my mind a little
bit of your mind a little bit and then
you call them do what you got to do
you're playing crime stopper you make
your [ __ ] statement
tommy you ain't paying for [ __ ] that you
didn't hit the car it's your word
against his yeah did you see him do it
no then who the [ __ ] are you you know i
don't hit nobody office you wanna check
my police record here's my social
security do a background check i'm not
into this [ __ ] okay i'm not paying and
i'm not [ __ ] gonna
file the claim of my insurance company
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him and stick to your guns
yeah don't take [ __ ] from nobody i don't
give a [ __ ] you're right you're right
lee it's not like you're a piece of [ __ ]
like me and none you're a nice american
jewish [ __ ] kid god damn right okay
you pay your taxes you never rob nobody
they've never done none for nobody you
stick up for yourself you didn't hit
this [ __ ] look me up i didn't
then [ __ ] wrong [ __ ] them all in the
ass tell allstate to suck your dick to
send the president of the united states
to give you a check for insulting you i
do have to call the post office because
they they lost my [ __ ] tax check it's
[ __ ] sitting in baltimore for some
reason so i gotta call them
where's the address it's in [ __ ] san
francisco
i don't know
thank god i got tracking on it well
cancel the check and send another one
and move on with your [ __ ] life
remember if you stop the check you'll
redo it in 30 days because they can
still bang that's why i don't want to do
that i was going to call them and see if
they're going to send it back or
something
and that's it that's all i got i've
always [ __ ] you in the ass oh um for
people who are out since i'm moving i
have one more week of shirts and then
i'm going to stop it for a little bit so
if you want one go to lisa.com if not
i'll bring them back in like a few weeks
once once i move get it together you
can't stop them you got to keep mailing
so forget that [ __ ] you can't shut down
i have to say there's no shutting down i
saw that last night it can't shut down
you can't just shut down leave for a
week gotta keep moving but i don't want
i don't want to leave these people
hanging you're not gonna leave them
hanging you're gonna mail them you don't
have nothing to do in the daytime lee
you have so much [ __ ] time
so much [ __ ] time in your day yeah
what are you talking about really why
what do you do
you leave here at 8 30. you got till 10
o'clock tonight to do something how long
do you think it's going to take you to
take a walk call it because you're done
by lunchtime no yeah
now i got i got a lot what
that's it you got to go for a walk what
else put the priorities okay i'm going
for a walk right
calling insurance in the car the cops i
have to call the the police i'm looking
at tonight right yeah and i got i have
[ __ ] joshua at seven that's 12. he's
got seven hours to kill you got seven
hours while i'm moving i don't want to
leave these people hanging you're not
gonna move you're gonna it's only taking
you one day to move you got to bed in
the front one day you got two hours in
your day to me don't ever shut nothing
down you're in operation do businesses
shut down because they're gonna move now
yes they do no they don't they have
movies they'll [ __ ] shut down for a
little bit no they don't they keep
[ __ ] going they keep they keep the
hope alive you just can't stop because
you're moving you think you got this
busy day but most of your day you're
sitting on that [ __ ] bed on the
computer i know this
but yeah but you gotta know that that
those days are done with you're gonna
move all [ __ ] day from now on doug
those days are done with this is all
part of the new [ __ ] league this is
all part of the new lead you give
yourself a lot of time to relax leave
a lot of time to relax it's too much
well it's not relaxed you're single you
don't see your girlfriend in the daytime
you don't have a cat you don't have a
dog you have nothing you ain't that
[ __ ] busy you gotta get on it that's
it with the [ __ ] stories no more in
bed throwing [ __ ] m m's up in the air
i'm like a [ __ ] thing i know you
you're gonna keep selling shirts you
gotta keep moving forward you're gonna
fill your days from now on no more
sitting in a [ __ ] house you're 25
years old
at 25 i didn't have a [ __ ] house i
didn't even watch tv at 25. i didn't
even know what baseball was i don't know
who won the 20 somebody told me the
twins won the world series i don't
[ __ ] know when the twins won the
world series you're 25. there's no more
tv in your life do the computer and what
you got to work it's over boston red sox
don't put money in your pocket near this
[ __ ] half these [ __ ] shows you
watch you sit there all day like a
[ __ ] move you're going to keep
selling shirts you're going to keep
digging and you're going to keep walking
this is the new league you lived a
certain way till you're 25 now the next
25 yeah live like a [ __ ] savage
enough is enough you're a young man
for all you young [ __ ] out
there with your playstation and your
[ __ ] if you're not getting your
dicks up to 25 or 25 i didn't know what
a [ __ ] couch was or a bet and i wish
i wish in my heart i was trying to be
funny with you dumb [ __ ] i
really wish in my heart i was trying to
be funny i slept three hours a [ __ ]
day and that's when i wasn't doing blow
do you understand when i was doing blow
there was no sleep what is this that
you're tired that you don't feel good i
don't even get you high in the morning
no more
if you want to go home and sleep because
you stayed up all night like a [ __ ]
mooc worrying about a car you didn't do
you didn't do nothing
well it's fun go home take a walk it
takes three years to get out of off your
thing
you didn't do nothing so it's what three
years are you worried about knock it off
you didn't do nothing i know it's your
word against them you caught i didn't
hit this guy and i'm not paying make
that in your [ __ ] report then you
call often you go look i know what this
[ __ ] guy's talking about i got the
proof right here as a matter of fact i'm
feeling dizzy from this because i'm
jewish i don't like being accused my
[ __ ] my culture has been accused for
[ __ ] two thousand years you know what
i'm getting dizzy i'm gonna go to i'm
gonna go to the hospital i think i'm
having a heart attack and then you're
gonna sue for [ __ ] damages because it
caused you to have a heart attack and to
get dizzy i don't know how to be a jew
if you're gonna be a jew wait until he
starts getting notices from a hospital
bill that you [ __ ] had to fainted and
you're getting flashbacks of vietnam
he's gonna tell you i i don't think lee
[ __ ] hit me with the car i thought it
was some other [ __ ]
jew walking around that's it lee these
last 25 years you lived them this way
and now you're gonna live like a [ __ ]
savage all right we're going into the
jew army that's it we're gonna make the
jew army reason to have his own film
festival the church or what's happening
now film festival oh yeah it's great
we're planning some stuff for january
[ __ ] submissions comedy shows comedy
and live panel [ __ ] podcasts we don't
get invited to do nothing we're gonna
make our own [ __ ] festivals and
we're doing a [ __ ] tour across new
jersey we're gonna start in northern new
jersey we'll do a podcast on wednesday
night in middle new jersey and the
weekend we're gonna just go to a
different [ __ ] bar we're gonna post
it on twitter where we're at at five
o'clock you got three hours to get there
[ __ ] that's how we're doing in 2000
the end of 2014 so your days are resting
there's no more rest i'm not resting
there no more resting who's who's your
sleep when you're dead
well
get a little bit of sleep
you're going to be a [ __ ] soldier lee
i'm putting you into a lean
mean slinging dick machine you
understand me you're a jew you're a
[ __ ] jew you're not some [ __ ]
angler walking around confused thank you
for that you got people that did things
your cousins with moses
you got your people good things whatever
your people [ __ ] did things they
parted rivers they slung dick
they got they tried to stop the jew you
imagine that that somebody tried to stop
the jew at one point and you're tired
i'm tired i don't feel good i'm on my
bed think of those jews in those [ __ ]
caves with those for wigs on with
tattoos on their hand you think they
didn't want to [ __ ] get the
get the [ __ ] out of there
i was the head
of the department when i wake when i
wake up in the morning i think about my
sister i think about my cousins in cuba
thinking about
those [ __ ] little black kids with
flies that i'm in africa how they don't
have the opportunity to go do a podcast
i don't have half the opportunities we
got we complain about everything as
[ __ ] americans we complain about but
put the anthem on that's it it's time
for a [ __ ] anthem that's it
i'm pissed off [ __ ] it's that
time when you guys get me fired up you
think when i wait when i wake up in the
[ __ ] morning yeah i think about
how many dicks my mom sucked to leave
that [ __ ] country
hey think about it put the [ __ ] music
only okay there you go
wake up [ __ ] it's over
when i wake up in the morning i think
about the the drama my mother put up
with and my father how much [ __ ] they
put up in cuba and how many dicks my
mother suck to leave that [ __ ]
country to get me you're a jew lee if
you're irish italian polish
if you're a [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you
are get up you're an american now i
don't give a [ __ ] what you were it's
what you are [ __ ] you know what
your parents did they [ __ ] get you
here and you're waking up playing pay
station you want to go to some community
college with momos you want to go to
vote tech i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
english think of what your ancestors did
think about what they did and then think
about what you're gonna do you're gonna
grab your [ __ ] you're gonna eat some
chinese food you're gonna get up and
you're gonna go out there and stab a
[ __ ] because that's what it
means to be an american getting out
there every day and doing it no matter
what the [ __ ] outcome is who gives a
[ __ ] they kick you in the head you eat a
roast beef sandwich and you get back out
there and do it again and again the next
[ __ ] day [ __ ] until somebody
says you're the [ __ ] man you're
an american
have a great week
this is me the [ __ ] off
oh yeah are we done you're done
okay
oh my god now that the show's over don't
forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com
you'll get high quality ranges up to
your door each and every month for
fractions of what you pay at retail go
to dollarshaveclub.com support slash
church or go to joeyds.net and click on
the dollar shave club banner the show is
also sponsored by naturebox.com order
great tasting healthy snacks at 50 off
snack smarter in the new year with
healthy and delicious treats like french
toast granola support this podcast and
get 50 off of your first order go to
naturebox.com and use promo code joey
naturebox.com promo code joey and again
thank you hold on i'm not disrespecting
if you're hindu or arabic you're an
american today [ __ ] get it
together too i didn't mention you guys
you don't want to leave anybody out and
now that life.com for all you oil and
wax smokers out there go there for the
premier favorite panel on the market and
save 20 off when you mention joey diaz
this was crazy
put the music on while you're pissing me
off
what are the questions
we ain't [ __ ] around today baby have
a great weekend we love you with all our
this is bad for them
god damn
oh
[ __ ] the [ __ ] rolling stones
coming at you [ __ ]